[Musique]
et notre invité politique ce matin c'est
ça va sur chenilles bonjour merci
beaucoup d'être député du nord porte
parole du rassemblement national on est
ensemble pendant 20 minutes pour une
interview en partenariat avec la presse
quotidienne régionale représentée par
stéphane vernets bonjour stéphane
bonjour il ya un petit dirige le bureau
parisien du journal ouest france
on commence par la loi séparatisme voté
hier à l'assemblée nationale adopté
j'allais dire à l'assemblée nationale le
vous et les députés du rassemblement
national vous êtes abstenu sur ce texte
pourquoi oui nous nous sommes abstenus
pour deux raisons d'abord c'est un texte
qui manque c objective son objectif si
l'objectif c'est bien de lutter contre
l'islam radical contre l'islamisme blanc
il faut le dire et il faut s'en donner
les moyens
ce texte il est très en dessous de
désespoir qu'on aurait pu avoir
légitimement si on estime que la menace
est fort dans notre pays elle est forte
dans le pays donc par conséquent ce
texte qui ne parlent pas d'immigration
qui ne dit pas réellement qu'il lutte
contre l'islamisme qui fait l'économie
des moyens et des mesures fortes qu'on
serait en droit d'attendre
il manque son objectif et puis de
l'autre côté nous n'allions pas votez
contre nous ne sommes d'ailleurs pas une
opposition systématique nous ce qui nous
intéresse c'est comment on protège les
français il ya quelques mesures de
police administrative quelques
mesurettes qu'on a voté quelques
articles qu'on a voté donc par
conséquent à partir du moment où on
s'est dit qu'il y avait quelques
mesurettes qui allaient dans le bon sens
servait à rien de faire de l'opposition
systématique c'est pas le texte qui
résout le problème
loin de là qui essuie en parlant de
d'opposition systématique vous visez la
droite
oui mais peut on était contents mais pas
ses mots jeudi à d'autres la france est
soumise à voter contre aussi mais
simplement je crois que les républicains
ils ont voulu dans cette histoire là se
donner bonne conscience lorsqu'ils ont
été aux responsabilités
le moins qu'on puisse dire c'est qu'ils
n'ont pas été à la hauteur sur les
sujets de sécurité s'était d'ailleurs
probablement est largement une déception
dans l'électorat de nicolas sarkozy qui
a amené françois hollande à être élu
donc aujourd'hui il essaye d'être
allez messieurs plus plus plus haut
toujours en faire plus le problème des
républicains soul et c'est que
lorsqu'ils sont en hémicycle il
bomber le torse et demande des mesures
très dures et puis dans la réalité c'est
autre chose moi je suis élu l'argent des
hauts de france xavier bertrand ont fait
des discours sur vos plateaux dans la
réalité subventionne des structures qui
ont un lien avec l'islam radical
donc si vous voulez tant que race cette
espèce d'hypocrisie et bien
effectivement vous aurez des gens qui
parleront très fort et qui n'agiront pas
non préfère être des gens constructif et
puis agir avec des mesures c'était le le
contre-projet qu'on a présenté avec
marine le pen avec des mesures qui nous
semblent cohérentes qui nous semblent
exigeante mais qui vont bien dans le
sens que nous souhaitons c'est à dire
interdire lutter contre l'islamisme dans
le pays
mais sauf que votre rien de ce qui était
dans votre contre-projet n'a été n'a été
retenue non rien à rien n'a été retenu
vous avez raison c'est vrai que le
gouvernement a été très sectaire nous
nous avons voté un certain nombre de
dispositions
quand on estimait qu'elle est dans le
bon sens même si elle était tout petit
même si elle est élue voiture est donc
pas rigoler mais nous les votants parce
qu'on se dit pourquoi en faire
l'économie
mais c'est vrai que de l'autre côté le
gouvernement n'a rien retenu de ce que
nous lui avons proposées moi je regrette
toujours cc positionnement politique
vous savez on l'a déjà vécu avec la
fermeture des frontières
pendant un an on a demandé à ce que les
frontières soient fermés dans notre pays
pour lutter contre la pandémie
le gouvernement par idéologie a refusé
puis finalement ils y sont venus les
mesures que nous proposons pour lutter
et pour interdire l'islamisme dans notre
pays nous y viendrons et le texte peut
être encore transformé au sénat
qu'est-ce que comment est ce que vous
pensez qu'il peut évoluer le texte moi
j'aimerais qu'il évolue enfin spir ans
de ce que nous avons proposé également
cible c'est une illusion il faut pas
rêver le gouvernement a décidé de
maintenir son texte
à lui de ne prendre aucun amendement ou
très très peu je crois qu'il en a eu un
ou deux qui ont été qui ont pu être
retenue de la part des oppositions
c'est un sujet mais c'est la droite qui
est majoritaire au sénat la droite dit
qu'il manque un volet immigration dans
ce test à dire sur dix que ce texte est
trop mou est ce que vous dites
le texte va sortir du sénat un texte il
reviendra à l'assemblée nationale alors
on verra bien ce que la droite fait mais
comme je voulais dit la droite dans
cette histoire là entre hypocrisie et
volonté de se donner bonne conscience
elle fait une sorte de cinéma permanent
tout ça n'est pas très utile et n'est
pas très sérieux
en réalité nous on a considéré on
considère toujours que nous avons devant
nous une menace qui est excessivement
importante qui étaient les guider depuis
l'étranger eh bien il faut se donner les
moyens
le problème c'est que ce texte il a une
portée tellement général qu'il en vient
à l'imiter d'ailleurs des libertés pour
un certain nombre de français qui n'ont
absolument aucun lien avec l'islamisme
on pense à l'instruction en famille
alors certes le ministre blanc caire a
décalé tout ça mais on voit bien que la
limitation de l'instruction en famille
il a fait voter un amendement disant
clastres la fin de l'instruction en
famille sera décalée à 2024 donc si vous
voulez mais il ya eu un compromis n'est
sûr par exemple sur cet article
famille est ce que le fait qu'il ne soit
pas interdite comme il est envisagé mais
qu'il soit soumis maintenant à
autorisation c'est un article qui vous
convient au nuc ont écouté en réalité
cet article là il est arrivé un peu
comme un cheveu sur la soupe parce qu'on
sait que le principal problème ne vient
pas de l'instruction famille l'islamisme
dans notre pays c'est pas uniquement
et c'est surtout pas finalement dans
l'instruction en famille qu'il est le
plus problématique ya beaucoup de
français qui placent leurs enfants enfin
qui instruisent leurs enfants en famille
pour des raisons médicales qu'on
contrôle très bien parce que je veux
dire c'est qu'on va limiter les libertés
des français qui ont ces problématiques
là au nom d'une lutte qui ne dit pas son
nom
disons les choses nous on a voulu
définir ce qu'était l'islamisme c'est
une idéologie est d'ailleurs en
définissant cette idéologie on évite
tous les amalgames avec la religion
islam alors définissant l'islamisme on
sait la combattre on sait empêcher son
financement est pas simplement contrôler
son financement dans le projet de loi
qui nous est soumis on est dans du
contrôle du financement
nous le votons bien sûr qu'il faut
contrôler mais faut aller beaucoup plus
loin
interdire le financement par des
puissances étrangères enfin voyez tout
ça est très timide et je dirais que
finalement ce texte il taquine
l'islamisme ça tourne autour on vient
peut lui mordre les mollets mais
finalement on ne prend pas cet ennemi
notre pays de la république cet ennemi
de la france de face et par conséquent
moi ce que je crains évidemment c'est
qu'on revienne à un moment ou un autre
devant le parlement dans les années qui
viennent pour se doter d'une législation
qui soit adaptée à la lutte contre
l'islamisme dans notre pays une
législation qui soit vraiment forte et
qui vise à interdire cette idéologie car
le but c'est de l'interdire on peut
interdire des idéologies dans notre pays
nous le faisons déjà
et tant mieux vous ne pouvez pas vous
revendiquez d'une idéologie nazie tant
mieux bravo il faut le faire eh bien
faisons la même chose pour l'islamisme
et vous ne pouvez pas vous revendiquez
d'être islamiste en france parce que la
france c'est l'égalité hommes-femmes
parce que la france est la laïcité enfin
voilà tout ce qui fait sécession avec
ces principes là doit être combattue il
en va quand même de l' équilibre de
notre pays se sont pas des mots ce qui
se passe dans notre pays on le voit à
trappes mais on peut le voir dans
d'autres coins de france moi je suis élu
du nord à roubaix ou dans d'autres
secteurs à maubeuge etc
on a des difficultés qui sont
excessivement forte et on a des pouvoirs
publics it ou sont démunis ou
hypocritement comme je les dis avec ce
cliché xavier bertrand ferme les yeux
pour des considérations électoralistes
on va parler de la clé sanitaire c'est
la ceinture leur confinement le
confinement en fait c'est quand toutes
les autres solutions n'ont pas
fonctionné sas avait été dit par marine
le pen un temps par vous également
est-ce qu emmanuel macron a bien fait de
ne par confiner une troisième fois
oui il a bien fait je crois que vous
soutenez sur ce point oui bien sûr
puisque nous avions demandé souhaité
qu'il n'y ait pas d'autres confinement
de 3e confinement nous ce que nous
pensons c'est que s'ils voulaient la
solution ça ne peut pas être couvre-feu
à 18h ou confinement confinement ou
couvre-feu à 18 heures il faut un moment
sortir de cela le fait que la solution
le labeur c'est d'avoir des politiques
qui anticipent un peu on a parlé depuis
longtemps du contrôle des eaux usées je
vois que ça se met petit à petit en
place
j'en suis satisfait mais ça fait
longtemps aussi que tout ça aurait pu
être décidé on avait parlé du contrôle
des frontières
il faut continuer les campagnes de tests
massive la vaccination
on voit bien que là encore ça n'a pas
été
allez je vais pas employer le mot fiasco
parce que je peux être désobligeant un
matin enfin quand même quand on ouvre
des centres de vaccination partout dans
le pays qu'on mobilise les élus qui se
mobilisent d'ailleurs eux mêmes
moi je le vois dans ma circonscription
je serai cet après-midi dans une commune
avec lui pour regarder un petit peu
comment ça se passe les vaccins n'arrive
pas donc les gens prennent des rendez
vous on attend le vaccin tout ça ne
fonctionne pas bien c'est pas fluide on
devrait bien bon le moins qu'on puisse
dire c'est tout ça n'a pas été bien
préparée s'il ya un mot qu'on puisse
retenir de cette pandémie ses
anticipations gouvernement savait très
bien que les commandes de vaccins par
l'union européenne est ce que c'est la
faulx vous avez vraiment si on n'a pas
les doses nécessaires
alors vous avez raison le gouvernement
ne portent pas toute la responsabilité
en cela aux avez raison souligné que
l'union européenne a été
particulièrement inefficace mais le
gouvernement s'est mis dans la main de
l'union européenne tous les
gouvernements n'ont pas fait le même
choix
certains ont négocié eux-mêmes
l'obtention de vaccins ils en ont eues
en nombre ils en ont eues en temps et en
heure ce n'a pas été le cas de la france
et puis ce qui m'inquiète aussi c'est de
voir que l'union européenne fait
prospérer son projet de de dossier
médical en tous les cas de passeports
médical dont deux passeports vaccinale
excusez-moi de passeports vaccinale je
le vois à travers les prises de position
dure cela van leyen et ça je trouve ça
très inquiétant non seulement l'union
européenne n'a pas été au rendez-vous de
l'efficacité mais maintenant on fait
prospérer passeport vaccinale que je
trouve bien contraire à notre
philosophie de non discrimination par
rapport à l'état médical des gens mais
aussi complètement à côté de la réalité
puisque je vous le rappelle que pour
qu'il y ait un passeport vaccinale qui
puisse fonctionner avec tout le monde
puisse avoir accès au vaccin
pour bien réfléchir à partir au moment
où tout le monde aura bien sûr
d'ailleurs lorsque tout le monde aura
accès au vaccin
en réalité ça voudra dire qu'on aura
plus ou moins vacciner 60 70 % d'une
population et donc que ce passeport
vaccinale n'aura plus beaucoup d'utilité
moi ce que je crois c'est que demain il
faut quand même levé la cloche
il faut redonner de l'oxygène et ligne
d'horizon aux français enfin on voit
bien le jeu c'est à dire supprimer
toutes les mesures et on en veut qu'on
engins non je ne dis pas ça veut dire
étoile des mesures sur d'abord avoir des
mesures qui soient adaptées au
territoire
on ne fait pas la même chose je
regardais aujourd'hui les chiffres alors
on ne fait pas la même chose dans les
alpes-maritimes qu'en bretagne
évidemment donc par conséquent
invariants britannique qui et on
comprend pourquoi la proximité avec la
grande bretagne un vaillant britannique
peut être source d'inquiétude en ce qui
concerne la multiplication des cas donc
on ne fait pas la même chose dans des
départements selon les cas de figure
et puis surtout on donne de l'oxygène
aux professionnels avec les gestes
barrière avec des mesures adaptées
j'étais déçu c'est ce que dans le nord
et dans le pas de calais il faut prendre
des mesures price a sauvé ce qu'il faut
en conflit n'est par exemple il s'agit
pas de reconfirmer moi je crois pas que
je vous ai expliqué qu'ils avaient toute
une batterie de possibilités avant qu'on
en arrive à durrës confinement je crois
qu'il corrige deux majeurs merci en tous
les cas les campagnes de tests massif
projet demandé par exemple voyez-vous à
la région que les campagnes de tests
soient faites cet effet dans d'autres
régions notamment en auvergne
rhône-alpes soit fait massivement sur
les lycéens on voit bien que le variant
britannique se répand plus vite il se
répand plus vite dans les jeunes
populations
ça veut pas dire car les plus graves vie
voilà ce pas dire qu'il est plus grave
mais en tous les cas ils contaminent
plus vite moi j'ai demandé que la région
qui a la responsabilité des lycées
engage des grandes campagnes de tests et
de dépistage dans les lycées c'est aussi
comme ça qu'on limite les choses ou ce
que vous souhaitez c'est des mesures
localisées aux régionalistes bien sûr
absolument des mesures nationales
absolument et puis et puis il va falloir
aussi un moment quand même que les que
ceux qui nous gouvernent comprennent que
les commerçants qu'un certain nombre de
commerçants là sont dans des difficultés
tellement immense que les mesures
aujourd'hui qu'ils sont plus nous
connaissons ne sont ou pas adapté où
doivent être repensées temps le jeune
tien est très fort en fond lit et quand
je veux
un exemple j'étais dans quelques
communes là encore du nord ou de ma
circonscription
ces derniers jours et des commerçants
nous explique les aides
le fonds de solidarité en particulier
nous sommes presque fin février ne sont
pas arrivés en décembre parisien en
janvier
parfois il ya des problèmes
administratifs parfois c'est très lent
les cas de figure sont toujours
complexes mais en attendant les
commerçants qui ont besoin de ces aides
ne les ont pas la mobilisation du monde
de l'assurance
je crois être déjà venu sur votre
plateau en fait une fois en en appelant
à la mobilisation du monde de
l'assurance
je vois des restaurateurs qui voient
leur prime d'assurance augmenter de 40%
sa société je leur faire cette publicité
alliance qui augmente ses prime de 40%
sur un certain nombre de restaurateurs
est-ce que c'est raisonnable est ce que
les assurances le seul engagement du
monde de l'assurance c'est de ne pas
augmenter des primes alors qu'en réalité
ils le font d'ailleurs est ce qu'en fait
la mobilisation du monde de l'assurance
peut se résumer à cela il faut être
beaucoup plus beaucoup plus exigeants à
un mot juste après finir sur cette crise
sanitaire puisque vous parlez des
frontières tout à l'heure est ce que
vous vous demandez la fermeture des
frontières avec la belgique pour
protéger département que moi je demande
un contrôle des frontières c'est à dire
qu'effectivement on puisse mais c'est
déjà le cas avec la belgique
quand vous passez en belgique vous êtes
contrôlés pas systématiquement
il n'y a rien mais moi je demande qu'il
y ait un rôle
donc je demande qu'il y ait un contrôle
des frontières bien sûr un contrôle et
une maîtrise des frontières et pas
seulement avec la belgique
pas seulement avec la belgique on va
passer au reste de l'actualité
un mot sur ce qui se passe actuellement
en nouvelle calédonie où un nouveau
gouvernement a été élu ce sont les
indépendantistes qui ont pris la tête de
ce gouvernement qu'est ce que vous en
pensez
bon de choses j'allais dire bon puisque
les les calédoniens ont souhaité que ce
soit les indépendantistes qui prennent
la relève dans ce gouvernement c'est la
démocratie qui s'expriment
j'entends ce message moi ce que je veux
dire c'est que nous avons besoin d'un
nouvelle calédonie est probablement la
nouvelle calédonie
est une entité française qui a besoin de
sa métropole
donc ne laissons pas se distendre la
relation entre la nouvelle calédonie et
la métropole et paris il faut évidemment
que nouer un dialogue permanent avec les
élus calédoniens si ce sont des
indépendantistes il faudra travailler en
tous les cas faire comprendre aux
calédoniens que nous avons besoin d'eux
qu'ils ont besoin de nous notre histoire
à les communes
elle est ancienne et elle n'est pas
faite pour se teindre cet amendement
surprise oui le gouvernement envisage la
possibilité d'un vote anticipé par par
le biais des machines à voter pour la
présidentielle de 2000 22 alors vous
avez des sénateurs de l'ouest qui sont
montés au créneau je pense notamment à
bruno retailleau ou philippe bas qui
parle de tripatouillage électoral quelle
est votre position par rapport à cette
proposition
enfin c'est quand même hallucinant à la
moindre possibilité à la moindre
ouverture ce gouvernement rentre dans
une espèce de faille pour essayer de
bidouiller une élection présidentielle à
venir qu'est ce que c'est que ces
idioties abbaoui que c'est que cette
histoire ait déjà vu des voix qui me
demandait par exemple à ce combat au
procès de vote par correspondance mon
existence repose et nous y sommes très
drôle et non pour les régionales nous y
sommes très opposés parce que ça ne
garantit pas évidemment la sincérité du
scrutin
les pressions peuvent être nombreuses je
dois dire que madame schiappa elle sur
le vote par correspondance mais le vote
en raison de l'aspect technique de toute
façon de tout ça n'est pas satisfaisant
un beau temps là vous parlez des
machines à voter
bien sûr nous avons anticipé est
tellement étrangers à la tradition
française que madame chez pas elle-même
avait dit il faut se prémunir se garder
de tout ces progrès entre guillemets
technique qui tiendrait pervertir la
démocratie est l'enjeu du scrutin moi je
crois que ce gouvernement au lieu d'être
obsédé par l'idée de tripatouiller les
élections devraient appliquer nous
devrait proposer aux français
l'une des mesures qui venait le
maquereau avait fait sienne dans son
programme qui est la proportionnelle qui
est demandé par quasiment l'intégralité
des partis politiques français à son
excellence est pas tout non parce qu'en
fait la proportionnelle ça permet de
mieux représenter l'ensemble des
sensibilités politiques
vous avouerez que trouver un texte qui
donne satisfaction à la fois aux
insoumis aux écolos un certain nombre de
socialistes communistes au modem au
rassemblement national à certains élus
des républicains à lui d y est
évidemment à la majorité en marche il ya
peu de textes qui font cette unanimité
et pourtant le gouvernement est en train
de caler eh bien nous nous l'appelons à
tenir ses engagements à faire vivre la
démocratie
le fait d'avoir une assemblée nationale
sincèrement avec six députés
rassemblement national alors qu'on sait
le poids que nous pesons que tous les
sondages donnent marine le pen au second
tour et petr et peut-être même tutoyant
la victoire ceci n'est pas raisonnable
dans une démocratie qui se veut mature
tous les pays presque tous les pays
européens je crois de mémoire utilise la
proportionnelle sous des formes très
différentes nous l'utilisons pour les
régionales nous l'utilisons pour les
municipales donc c'est un scrutin que
nous savons utilisez qui fait foi dans
le pays
arrêtons ces histoires de ces
bidouillages
technique allons vers des choses qui
anoblit ce le combat politique
un mot sur un texte qui arrive
aujourd'hui à l'assemblée c'est le texte
qui visait à modifier la constitution
pour garantir la préservation de
l'environnement est ce que vous êtes
favorable à ces congrès font la quantité
mais c'est déjà dans le dans les textes
en fait part d'un nouveau texte portant
non mais c'est là encore qu'est ce que
c'est que cette perte de temps c'est
dans le bloc constitutionnel
on le sait très bien donc je vois pas
bien ce que ça apporte moi j'aimerais
qu'on ait une écologie qui soit tournée
vers le localisme et pour ça ça veut
dire changer de paradigme ce texte
bon on votera pas mais là aussi c'est
bien sympathique il n'y a pas de raisons
de voter contre
en réalité sur le fond il n'y a pas de
raisons de voter contre mais qu'est ce
que ça apporte
changeons mais moi je vois pas pourquoi
on voterait contre je regarderai le
texte tomber les faits je regarderai les
débats mais ça change strictement rien
ce qui changerait ce serait de rompre
avec les traités de libre échange ce
serait de produire là lors plus proche
de là où on consomme ça ça changerait
les choses donc lens pour vous on
s'achemine vers un référendum inutile il
servirait à rien a préféré nous l'avons
déjà dit le président de la république
essaye d'utiliser la noble thématique de
l'environnement
une façon totalement incohérente par
rapport au résultat qu'on est en droit
d'attendre là encore par rapport aux
exigences qui sont hautes et importante
des français sur ces dans ces domaines
là moi je crois qu'il faut arrêter avec
des gadgets changement de paradigme
produisons à côté de là où nous
consommerons c'est le localisme c'est la
ligne que nous nous proposons
marine le pen est une ennemie de la
république c'est ce qu'a dit christophe
castaner ce week-end dans le parisien
qu'est ce que vous lui répondait devant
monsieur castaner est en contradiction
avec monsieur darmanin ce ne sera pas
probablement la première fois que rennes
ministre de l'intérieur tout ça est
ridicule et je crois que la politique de
l'insultent sur castanet râle insulte
aux lèvres comme monsieur dupont moretti
non seulement ne les grandit pas montre
qu'ils sont vraiment fébrile
le moins qu'on puisse dire et puis
surtout si leur seul combat c'est lutter
contre le rassemblement national
il se trompe d'objectif nous nous
travaillons nous faisons des
propositions pour protéger les français
et leur identité leur économie leur
sécurité
moi j'attendrais de gens qui sont aux
responsabilités
de nous dire là où ils veulent emmener
le pays pas d'insultés leurs adversaires
est ce qu'ils imaginent une seule
seconde que son propos va faire changer
un électeur du rassemblement national et
va empêcher quelqu'un d'être attentifs
au discours parfaitement républicain de
marine le pen
je note que marine le pen à part dans la
bouche de christophe castaner n'est pas
décrite dans les oppositions comme
quelqu'un de gentil républicain et hier
encore adrien cat-nat sur une chaîne
autre que la vôtre expliqué que
l'ensemble des personnes qui était élu à
l'assemblée nationale et est
parfaitement républicain
oui vous serez tête de liste du
rassemblement national aux régionales
dans l'est dans les hauts de france
qu'est ce quelle est votre stratégie
comment est ce que vous pensez vous
pouvez battre le président sortant
xavier bertrand devant moi ce que je
souhaite c'est être un président 100%
vous savez quand j'écoute le président
actuel bertrand il vous dit élisez moi
et je m'en vais tout de suite aux
élections présidentielles c'est amusant
parce que c'étaient leurs proches qu'ils
avaient fait à marine le pen la dernière
fois et ce côté un peu utilisé la région
donc c'est vraiment fait ce coup ça bien
sûr alors pour le coup c'est donc ça
démontre une telle sincérité
ça peut vraiment des arguments du vieux
politicards qu'utilise utiliser xavier
bertrand quand il disait ça puisqu'il
fait exactement la même chose
donc j'ai franchement c'est pas très
sincère moi je souhaite d'abord un
président à 100% je deviens président
effectivement qui mène une autre
politique
les régions elles vont devoir être aux
avant gardes des politiques nouvelles
qui vont à mon avis de voir se déployer
pour l'après que vides si on reprend les
mêmes types de politique c'est à dire
par exemple investir de l'argent public
sans avoir de retour en terme d'emploi
investir de l'argent public à des
associations je le disais tout à l'heure
qui ont des complicités avec l'islamisme
si on continue de cette façon là alors
là covin n'aura rien changé
moi je souhaite et j'assume une rupture
celle de protéger notre région celle de
flécher ces financements non seulement
en dehors de la métropole de lille mais
dans la ruralité dans notre région est
la fusion a été terrible parce qu'en
fait c'est lille qui aspirent tous et
bien moi je souhaite qu'on rééquilibre
tout ça dans la région sont envoyés
protéger rééquilibrer lutter contre
l'islamisme également au niveau régional
et président est réellement la région il
ya déjà des radis fait j'ai cru
comprendre ce dont s'était juste vous
vous lancer dans une campagne de
proximité vous allez faire le tour de la
région en bus mais c'est ça ce n'est pas
une méthode qui avait appliqué xavier
bertrand dernière fois je vais pas en
camping-car en camping car j'ai mis la
barre un peu plus haut puisque j'ai un
vrai bistrot
merci beaucoup merci manu da donne une
voix remercie ses fans on regarde la une
d'ouest france 0 cauvier de la france
peut-être suivre l'exemple d'autres pays
c'est à la une de votre journal merci
beaucoup ont pas suite aux claviers de
la victoire
la mutuelle nationale territoriale la
mutuelle des agents des services publics
locaux vous présente le club des
territoires angie acteurs engagés
n'aurait transition zéro carbone des
régions vous présente le club des
territoires
[Musique]